the subject of alternative views news
magazine for the evening is boy
prostitution
the widespread use and abuse of male
children for sexual purposes
some of the language in the program may
be offensive to some people
admittedly
the whole subject
is offensive
in 1979 there was a call boy ring
operated out of new york city
which had phone hookups with houston
atlanta los angeles new orleans
washington dc
and that call boy ring had a list of 10
000 clients
who could call and with a credit card
purchase a boy
hello
hello this is a
credit card number 06789 i'd like to
make an order please go ahead
i'm looking for a young male blonde hair
blue eyes
body hair nobody here thick body hair
please what age
10 to 12
butcher fam
butch
what is your address
i'm at the houston marriott hotel room
313.
wire me two hundred dollars now by
credit card and have a hundred dollars
in cash for the boy he'll be there in 30
minutes thank you thank you
in houston i i give the figure based on
i think prudent calculations that
upwards of 350 boys a year are killed
deliberately because of this many more
die of drug overuse
value malnutrition of suicide
the national toll per year
is in the thousands every year kids die
violently because of this
it's closely attached to
the major financial commercial
industrial
educational institutions of our society
it's run by the same people who run
those it's frequented by the same people
who occupy management positions in those
it's not the mafia
it's
it's an adjunct of clean business
it's serving the most respectable people
we have
in our society the people who are the
elite
prostitution of male children tonight
on alternative views news magazine
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight's program on alternative views
is one
which you may quite frankly not want to
watch
it's going to be very disturbing
the subject is very controversial even
disgusting
the language in some of them may be
offensive to some people
but we're going to find out tonight
about
the senior side of the american power
structure and maybe something about male
homo sapien
because the subject of tonight's program
is boys for sale boy prostitution
where these kids come from how they're
used how they're abused
tortured killed
used sexually and who is it that's doing
it
we find some very shocking things are
happening
we have with us tom philpot
the history department the university of
texas is a special guest in addition
mark mckinnon
former editor of the daily texan at the
university
tom has been doing a lot of research on
the subject and mark was involved in
some articles very controversial
articles
a couple of years ago
but before we have our program on boy
prostitution here are some new stories
well i guess most of you saw the movie
the day after
william f buckley
in his
magnificent mind
calls it sheer humbugry
and a result of junk thought
and then he he includes with this
buckley i don't know if he's he's just
getting senile or what i remember
oh a few months ago
he uh wrote an article saying that
if nicaragua continues to do what they
do we're going to declare war on them
and their backers cuba and the soviet
union go to world war ii over nicaragua
well anyway he talks about the nuclear
war this way remember this folks a
full-scale nuclear war would mean about
100 million americans dead those hundred
million are going to die one of these
days without nuclear anesthetic and they
will in almost any case die more
painfully and what the hell let's have
world war three yeah he is really
obscene
i think his mind got frozen in the 1950s
during the mccarthy period where he
literally believed that there was a
monolithic totalitarian evil in the
world the soviet union and everything
they do is bad everything we do to
counter this is good including you know
war and
militarism and even nuclear
war would be justified against this evil
it's almost sort of a very simplistic
christian view of this manatean
religious sect in the fourth century
that saw a battle between satan and the
lord as the primary forces of history
and that's buckley's mindset well there
are a lot of religious nuts now who are
welcoming the nuclear holocaust because
that would bring on the second coming of
jesus so let's let's don't have any of
this nuclear free stuff
well they're even trying to say that
nuclear war is okay in england the
ministry of defense in england
has a pr
propaganda
race going they're distributing
pamphlets and for a while they were
dickering with j walter thompson the big
american advertising firm for a 1.5
million dollar contract to produce slick
commercials praising nuclear bombs and
saying hey we can't let people bully us
around we need these things
they
the mother jones quoted
somebody from the campaign for nuclear
disarmament thermo and senior bruce kent
he was saying if there's any factor that
got the people in england upset it was
our own government civil defense program
telling people to protect themselves
against nuclear war by staying at home
by hiding under kitchen tables and white
washing their windows
a recent poll by the way indicates that
one half of the
british people are opposed to these
additional missiles being brought into
the british isles as are a growing
number of the germans there's been
several articles about the growing
resistance in germany to the
inflammation of these missiles
in germany
there was back in
september
first thing i've heard about it the u.s
soldiers had conducted a mass
mock burial exercise
called
well i'll save the name until later
anyway the exercise trained soldiers how
to use bulldozers to prepare for mass
graves in the case of nuclear war
in europe it's the first time according
to army stars and stripes that this
would occurred this came from counter
spy
magazine and the code name for this
exercise it was confident enterprise
wow i'm saying there's a very
interesting article in these times that
puts all of the new cold war in a very
good perspective and that is the reagan
administration has claimed that it's
tremendous spending on defense it's
building up of the nuclear arsenal the
spending on these military weapons
putting these weapons systems in europe
is all necessary because reagan claims
over the last five or six years the
russians have been increasing their
spending on weapons or developments of
new weapons whereas we've been
decreasing our spending and have fallen
behind the soviet union well this
article and in these times indicates
that this is total nonsense based on
complete myths and lies first of all
they point out that military spending
under the carter years did not decrease
as reagan claimed but increased
2.95 percent from 1977
through 1981. moreover the cia has just
come out with a report on soviet
economic trends and policy development
that claims that soviet spending for
military
weapons etc has declined over the last
years since 1976
and that their their spending
for new weapons and their development of
systems has been much lower than the
increases in american spending and the
cia in their report has documented this
in great detail moreover reagan
administration has been claiming that
one of the priorities of the end
drop-off administration in the soviet
union is also to develop new weapon
systems to increase military spending
etc whereas the cia report also
indicated that is complete nonsense that
there has been a drop of spending for
military means under and drop off who
has been dedicating the majority of his
new spending programs to non-military
civilian expenditures etc so that it's
total nonsense that the soviets are
spending more on
money on weapon systems and we're
spending less in fact during the same
period the reagan administration has
increased military spending
16.7 percent annually which is the
biggest buildup of military defense
spending in american history and in fact
the defense budget that was passed by
the reagan administration for the coming
year is the highest that has ever been
spent in u.s history no less than 249.8
billion dollars will be spent on
military spending by the reagan
administration next year which will
include new weapon systems such as the
mx nuclear missile the b1 bombers and
other billion-dollar programs for all of
these new missiles um systems in fact
the only systems that military systems
that the reagan administration didn't
get from congress was a nerve gas
program
twice the congress voted it down twice
the senate approved it on a tie vote
with george bush
casting the tie-breaking vote in both
cases but the senate house conference
committee killed the nerve gas program
both
times but otherwise reagan got all the
defense spending he wanted it's curious
that this cia report came out because
two years ago from the alternative press
you remember we carried stories with
just this such analysis
and the fact the cia seems to rediscover
this two years later is rather curious
and the fact that they would come out
with this right now is even more curious
reagan just plays fast and loose with
his statistics and facts he's literally
the biggest liar that we've ever seen in
the white house and there's been some
well along this same line
the reagan administration of course
still clings to the zero option
for europe meaning that soviets have to
dismantle all
or most of their existing intermediate
range nuclear missiles
and in return we will not deploy or use
the pershing 2 or cruise missiles
well
the counter spy
quoted a new congressional research
service study
which showed that the bases for
the reagan administration's claims that
they needed to do this were all false
mainly the fact
they were saying the soviets of course
say well we got to include the british
and french missiles in here
and
reagan says now we don't need to do this
because the french and british forces
are insignificant when compared to the
soviet arsenal but this new
congressional study says that isn't true
britain has four submarines with 16
six warhead missiles each
france has five nuclear submarine
marines with 16 multiple warheads each
and 18 land-based missiles and 34 mirage
planes which can drop a load on the
soviet union and they're working up to
1500 war warheads and since it only
takes a handful to destroy the country
well the that's a plenty i'm no it's not
too
well it's understandable the soviets
would be a bit upset about that
reagan also says that the british and
french forces are independent and
uncommitted u.s doesn't have any control
over it but this congressional study
says no that's not true the british
forces are going right along with and
planned in with those of the us and even
the french although they do have their
own control of it they are signatory to
some
pacs which indicate that they will
coordinate their military power with
those of the other european countries in
the u.s
reagan also says the british and french
arms are strategic and not theater
nuclear weapons well when they had the
assault negotiations the u.s was saying
it was just the opposite so it depends
on what negotiations are using they
label them the other way
and that's our news segment this evening
now let's turn to our main focus
boy prostitution
well i'm drained already after talking
to you people for a couple of days about
this subject i'm absolutely shocked and
i feel degraded too as a member of the
human race
tom can you first give a case history
just kind of a typical case history and
then we'll talk in greater detail about
what happens
all right i i can tell you the biography
of a little kid
from a hollow in west virginia
whose mom and dad went to houston to
find work they thought that houston was
the capital of opportunity in america
the dad went out there to get a job a
low-level job with an oil company
brought the mother then sent for little
jimmy and his little brother
jimmy and his brother got to houston on
a
greyhound bus
and
his dad mom failed to pick them up how
old were they jimmy at that time was 12
and his little brother was six
they spent the night
in the terminal
jimmy fending off the advances of a
number of men
and then the dad came to pick him up the
next morning the parents had both gotten
drunk and
forgotten to pick up the kids
the boys went to live with their parents
the parents both had severe drinking
problems the dad lost his job
the mother got killed in a car wreck the
little boy was severely injured
jimmy dropped out of school to try to
hustle was his word
money to help keep the family
what was left of it together
the dad died
choking in his own vomit after a
drinking bout
and jimmy was the sole support
of himself and his little brother
the rent was coming round and jimmy had
no money and then a neighbor kid said to
him
you can get ten dollars just for
watching me
play with a man
and jimmy said that's queer
and his friend said it's not queer if
the guy does it to you
if you just let it happen and all you
have to do is watch
jimmy did it
then the man offered jimmy 25
to let the man play with jimmy and jimmy
took it so he had 35
and then he got introduced into the
routine jimmy was little
only 12 and he was small for his age
and the circuit he went on in houston
was not the main one which is montrose
he went to a place nearby
an arcade called fun land
the way that worked was the boys would
stand by the machines and a man would
come by if the man offered quarters the
boy would take him and the man and the
boy would go off
jimmy became a professional prostitute
at the age of 12.
he survived in that capacity until he
was 14. was he working on his own or was
he part of an organization he was not
part of an organization he was what they
call the farm league
and he was taking care of his little
brother
his brother got killed in a car wreck
when he was driving with some people
and
jimmy then was desolate
and almost destitute he used the last
money he had to bury his brother
he did not want to let his last
surviving relative his grandpa and west
virginia know
the way things had gone
uh
a reporter in houston last saw jimmy
across the street from fun land
and a man who used to
pay boys for sex then told this reporter
i know that boy
he told a man who's a friend of mine
that
one time he was having sex with that
little boy
and then he realized that the boy was
crying and he looked up and saw that the
boy was sucking his own thumb
and at that point he had to break off
the encounter
the journalist believes that this
reformed
man who used to use boys was
his own best friend the boy who had been
having sex with jimmy
jimmy disappeared
his body was later found mutilated
and his grandfather was notified
the police
then told
the grandpa in a very cruel way
that the grandpa shouldn't try to get a
loan from the city of houston it would
cost five hundred dollars
to ship the body ship the body to west
virginia because the boy was nothing but
a harbor [ __ ]
or worse
and the grandpa died shortly thereafter
the whole family is dead
now
jimmy was a typical kid
he wasn't looking for this life he found
it he needed some means of support he
took what he could get and he came to
grief and met his death
houston is
possibly the worst city in the united
states
for the misuse of
lost and runaway boys or homeless
defenseless boys probably 350 or more
boys are killed every year in houston
about houston i would say i hear about
houston that it is the worst
uh that children are brought to houston
from places such as new orleans or from
other parts of the southwest their life
is sad it's 100 sad they get up you know
one or two or three during the day and
they go out and they have to earn money
and they're treated bad
they eat only when they're
fed by somebody else and they never get
anything for anything they always have
to return sexual favors for it they
sometimes get beaten they get robbed
they get pushed you know the police
abuse them everybody abuses them one
young man got out of a car by a young
man i mean the age of probably 15 maybe
16. he got out of the car and he was
just badly beaten i mean there's no toys
about he looked right at him his face
was black and blue and blood coming out
his nose and his lip was fat and he
couldn't walk very well and he was sick
to his stomach in the bushes and
he was just very badly beaten evidently
he had got either a bad trick or the man
was on s m or something just kind of
like shoved him out of the car he went
around the corner
opened the door for me said get out
any of them ever want to hurt you
that's why i watch out for them you
watch out for them yeah how do you tell
no they start to jump now
or jump on you yeah if they do
i'll get it i'll be ready because i'll
be watching every time what do you be
doing then
i should be laying down in bed let them
just watch what if they start to jump on
you what can you do i always carry a
pocket knife or something like that i
don't know if that hurt me or not you
know i just watch out for them
just in case they do start
nine out of ten i'm weird
i mean
they get you know
there was one guy that picked me up in
atlanta
and
he just said you know he wanted somebody
to go out and have a few beers when he
would smoke a joint
and we got over there and
i was drinking this beer and all of a
sudden you know
doing like that you know i couldn't even
see straight my eyes were rolling back
and then the room started spinning and i
was out of it when i came around he had
me tied up
in the basement no less way up like this
you know
and i couldn't even move did you tie it
up yeah it stretched how's he doing to
you
nothing he was just sitting there with
this whip looking like he's gonna hit me
with it he just threatened me a lot and
i was sitting there crying i'm scared to
death
you know because the worst i could do is
kill me
that interview was conducted several
months ago in houston texas
investigators now fear that the
15-year-old is dead the body of a young
man found ritualistically dismembered in
missouri is thought to be his
i woke up and he had he was planting
handcuffs on me
i was laying on my stomach the other two
were on their stomach and they were
handcuffed and their feet were tied the
most shocking and horrifying result of
older men having sex with young boys is
the story of dean coral in houston texas
and more recently john gacy in chicago
in houston carl lured or had brought to
his home at least 27 young boys all
under the age of 17. the boys were
sexually assaulted then killed
in houston
i give the figure based on
i think prudent calculations that
upwards of 350 boys a year are killed
deliberately because of this many more
die of drug overuse
malnutrition of suicide the national
toll per year
is in the thousands every year kids die
violently because of this
in the first three months of
this year
1981.
30 boys were found dead
in houston
none of them was called a homicide
they were
found to be dead of exposure
debt of cause is undetermined
dead of massive internal bleeding
as in the case of one child under 10 who
was found naked in a dempsey dumpster
with his colon and his rectum torn apart
he was called not a homicide but a
victim of massive internal
injury he was fist raped yes what is the
sort of psychic roots or the nature of
this phenomenon
i've been studying this phenomenon since
the spring of 1979
and to the best of my knowledge most men
who seek sex from boys
are not homosexuals
to the extent that they have active sex
lives uh at the peer level
they are heterosexual
many of them have no peer sex at all
there are
gay people who are
what we call peteris that is men who
lust after children especially boys
but it appears to be the case that most
such men are not gay
that their
attraction is for
young
defenseless
children especially boys because they're
more exotic more forbidden
but
it is not a matter of
gay
rights as advocated by practically
anybody this is a
a much different sort of phenomenon the
reason that the gay community
usually
scorns any investigation of the subject
is that they know
that the average person in the public
will blame homosexuals and homosexuality
for the phenomenon regardless of what
facts are presented
well this is not just a sexual thing in
the way we talk about it it's a
power trip and it's also
a sadistic thing because these kids are
tortured and killed kind of individuals
involved are down the line
almost in every instance in the cases
i've investigated men who are very
powerful usually very wealthy
and usually administrate control over a
large number of people
wealthy houstonians can and do obtain
boys in a most discreet manner it's
gotten a little more sophisticated now
it's gotten more
it's gotten more expensive
prices higher prices are paid
and it's
it's gotten a little more sophisticated
in terms of
oh
i think the types of people who are who
are into it types of adults who are into
it professional people
uh
houston professional people yeah
soliciting boys oh sure
you know i mean be a millionaire in
houston man
yeah you have people here that are so
wealthy that they can't let anybody know
what they're doing that they're willing
to pay two three four hundred dollars a
night
you know for one of these boys not to
say anything about them you know you've
got judges doctors lawyers politicians
advertising people involved in
buying young people
if it's for an hour for a night or for a
month or for a year
they actually have white slavery in this
country it's a fact
in houston right now it's going on tom
is there any
evidence that there's any connection
with organized crime obviously with
other forms of prostitution that we know
about there are close connections the
mafia has always utilized prostitution
as one of the pillars of its
organizations and sources of its income
is there any connection here that has
been revealed uh with organized crime
yes when we're talking about 400 kids on
the street between two and four in the
morning in a city like houston
there's very little organization there
may be a runner or a pimp who's trying
to squeeze the boys a little but there's
no big businessman running a
sophisticated operation
but when there is a bookstore with 40
stalls
there's often a stable of boys that's
that's fairly good-sized business and
there's bigger business than that that's
the call boy operations like this one we
described with the 10 000 customers
that's big business it's crime it's
organized but it's not the mafia
it's
the pillars of our society
there is big business organized crime
it's sophisticated it's closely attached
to
the major financial commercial
industrial
educational institutions of our society
it's run by the same people who run
those it's frequented by the same people
who occupy management positions in those
it's not the mafia
it's
it's an adjunct of clean business
it's serving the most respectable people
we have
in our society the people who are the
elite i assume you can't name names at
this particular time
but none of people haven't been
apprehended yet right okay
are senators involved
u.s senators well what congressman do
you suppose let me give you some
information here now this is stuff that
has come out of
newspaper clippings it has gotten far
enough to get in the newspaper even if
it hasn't been followed up
this was potentially the biggest case of
all
that the one in new orleans yes a new
orleans boy scout troop
was busted for actually being a call boy
ring of boy prostitutes
the man who was the leader of the boy
scout troop was given 75 years in prison
and then he offered to tell a story
the story he told was that the
congressional delegations from two
states one of which was louisiana and
one of which bordered louisiana
and as he put it the entire hierarchy of
one of the states as far as top
political posts
were all involved as customers of the
little boys
and he said he was willing to name all
the names
that was a upi story of 26 november 1979
and he never talked again
as he said
he's still in jail he said there was one
u.s senator in many congressmen weren't
there a couple
actually right wing
new right
representatives congressmen in
washington
who were actually
well found guilty of molesting
doug
i wish you were right
congressman robert bauman
was apprehended in february of 1980
having sex with a 16 year old boy
for some reason
no charges were brought until september
1980
at that point the fbi and the u.s
attorney made an agreement to keep all
details of the account out of public
records
the charges were dropped on bauman's
promise that he would take a drug or an
alcoholic abuse
treatment program he continued in office
and he ran for re-election
he was defeated but he said he would go
on to run again
william f buckley is one of his closest
friends they were co-founders of young
americans for freedom and the american
conservative union
the way buckley put it was this
it transpires that during alcoholic
bouts he engages in homosexual acts
he went on to say there was a complaint
filed by a 16 year old boy
then he went on to say bauman should
resign from congress and resign from the
positions in conservative organizations
because he was an embarrassment
obama never went to trial
he didn't actually go to a formal
pre-trial hearing either then there was
a texas congressman wyatt
who was caught
well actually i take away he was not
caught a
juvenile reported that why did force sex
on him
charges were never filed that's a quote
charges were never filed despite the
fact that the boy had filed a complaint
and wyatt said he was going to run again
when it was published in the austin
paper that
the complaint was not that he was drunk
driving but that he had forced sex on a
juvenile male he said he wouldn't
run again
he was already in the alcohol
rehabilitation program so there was no
trial no pre-trial hearing no charges
wasn't there another another ring of
tour guides boys tour guides for
congressman well that you may be
referring to the case of representative
hinson republican from mississippi who
was found having sex with somebody in
the men's room of the longworth
house office building
their conflicting accounts according to
one account he was having sex with a
minor according to another account he
was having sex with an adult
he
said he was innocent
and he agreed to undergo alcohol abuse
treatment
and he was not charged
there were so many charges were dropped
what was the story about the
about the young boys being tour guides
for the capitol and this was also part
of
a little boy sex ring and also
some of it resulted in campaign
contributions i read that in order that
has to do with the state of texas as a
matter of fact and uh
here's the way we can tell that story
this is one you can't tell well we can't
it got into the newspaper yeah i saw it
in the newspaper but then it disappeared
what appeared in the newspaper was a
boy's home run by a texas state
representative
was being investigated for charge of
abuse of the boys
the state representative said that there
was no abuse he claimed that his his
place could not be investigated by the
state because it was private like that
of lester
reverend roloff
the story died and didn't appear in the
press anymore
the lead
that
produced the initial story was that that
representative took campaign
contributions and then
the
contributors
as a reward got to have sex with the
boys in the home
and that he did this for more than
himself but for other representatives
that man is out of the state legislature
so we've talked about legislators
congressmen
a senator senators
people in the
the highest ranks of the government at
the local at the state level now are
these just aberrations or is this part
of
a widespread ongoing thing
i think it's very widespread
and not just among powerful politicians
we've talked about politicians
but
it seems to be the case that in all
high-powered professions
corporations now we're talking about two
corporations medicine
law
even the university
not necessarily professions with
bloated salaries but prestige
some power
influence and above all pressure
the men involved are susceptible to this
kind of deviation i'm working right now
you know
like
just you know with the corporation
and
what's that how does that work
well
when their executives or
you know their business people are in
town
they're sent to our apartment
and we entertain them while they're here
okay what's that entertainment usually
involved what do they usually demand or
what do they want
well it's all kinds of sex and
perversions there's no two alike i've
decided that
everyone's in for something different so
i can't really stereotype the hope yes
all the men want different things yeah
right
but we're usually
in the passive
side and they're usually the dominant
player
he was a real old
what does he do at grady hospital
he's
one of those that
[Music]
operates on people he's a what a doctor
we've talked about those men who have
achieved power
and also among those men who wanted it
but didn't get it
men like poor gacy in chicago who killed
at least 33 boys
he was not a well-to-do man but he was a
joiner he paid high dues to join men's
clubs he paid a thousand dollars to join
the president's club so he could have
dinner with jimmy carter instead he had
dinner with mrs carter and had his
picture taken with her he was a an
upwards driver
he killed at least 33 boys
he offered in his defense that he could
not identify any of the 33 boys by face
or by name because he had had sex
with fifteen hundred different boys in
the previous five years
three hundred different kids a year
and most of them as he said were
prostitutes
he didn't snatch them off the street he
went out and
bought their services and then
he coerced them as this lawyer in
washington says no one ever does
he made them captives and he killed them
what about women in the positions of
power in government you don't find women
involved in that well you don't find
many women involved in positions of
power in the uh america maybe that
explains the
what appears to be the fact
women don't do this to little girls
heterosexual women homosexual women
don't do this to little girls or a
little boy or little boys
i mean it happens but it's not common
it's not ordinary it's not a phenomenon
it in a threat
if you have a little girl and you have
an adult female friend you needn't have
any apprehension
but if you have little kids who are boys
they are in more danger than the little
girls today
why do you think there's so much
violence caught up in this
investigations in other cities have
shown that boys 13 14 even younger are
coerced into prostitution with threats
of physical violence and are sometimes
shipped across state lines shipped to
the older adult men who desire young
boys for sexual acts occasionally these
boys episodes with their older clients
ends in physical violence there are men
who seek young boys to torture and
sometimes to kill this phenomenon is not
unique to america
it may not even be unique to advanced
industrial urban societies in the other
places where it occurs though it doesn't
seem to be attended by a high level of
mayhemic violence and in the united
states it is in islamic countries for
instance prostitution with boys is a
standard i've been in morocco and
algeria and observed this and yet i've
never heard any stories of violence
being involved in other words it's an
erotic phenomenon as opposed to this
power or psychological
well there are those who would have us
believe that that is the case in america
here for instance is an article written
by a law professor in washington d.c
who was general counsel to the
metropolitan police department this
article was written in 1981
he says if the boys are victims it is
largely in the technical sense it is
more accurate to characterize them as
entrepreneurs
who by and large understand their own
motivations they do it for money for
drugs for pleasure and perhaps for some
is a crude gambit for emotional
sustenance but unlike teenage girl
prostitutes they do not act out of fear
there is no coerced recruitment no
whippings no incarcerations in their
rooms and no sweet talking pimps with
cadillacs
that's not what i have found
so you think i said false that
washington police chief i think it's
false and i think it's a deliberate
falsehood
well let's talk about we haven't talked
about the proliferation in the united
states
of this we've talked about a few
individual cases how widespread is it
and what are the numbers we're talking
about
well we know this for instance this is a
standard a half a million kids run away
or are thrown out of homes every year in
the united states and the majority of
them are boys
another thing that the
president's commission on obscenity
found this is the commission that
richard nixon repudiated
it mentioned in passing
that child pornography was a phenomenon
of the abuse of children and then went
on to say that for every female
prostitute of any age in the united
states there are nine boys
underage who are prostitutes
that is a finding which is debatable and
it is a speculation
but it went unnoticed
uh
i think though that if uh
if you get in a car and prowl the
streets of
the capitals of this
practice houston
new orleans atlanta
chicago new york los angeles
and to a much lesser extent
austin our state capitol and washington
the nation's capital
you'll find that boys are the ones
hustling more than the women
mark some of the research that you did
in austin here that started off your
involvement in this issue indicated that
there was a
possible ring of homosexual boys in
austin can you tell some of the facts on
this case well my interest in this whole
issue originated when
as a reporter for the daily texan we
heard
through the grapevine that a pharmacist
here in town
had been busted
and i don't remember the original
charge i'm not sure if the use of a boy
in a home i guess it was abusive that's
right abuse of a boy in a halfway house
well the thing that interested us about
the case
was that the police had later found in
his home
a file an index file
of anywhere from two to five hundred
names of young boys
in the around the travis county area in
counties
accompanying travis county
and it had their names phone numbers
parents names in many cases
sexual
statistics on the on the personnel
height age weight
and in some cases preferences
and that sounded like an astounding
thing to us that there should be
somebody traveling around and what he
did was he would hang out at high
schools and
and offer the drugs that he had
available as he was a pharmacist
in exchange for sexual
favors
well we followed that up and and
somewhere down the line of judicial
scrutiny
the entire
the evidence was lost or disappeared or
was unable to be retracted
and
that
it complicates from there but that's a
that's how we got well anderson his name
was anderson robert anderson he was
found
guilty of one charge and sentenced to
two years in prison
and then he skipped he was he was still
not incarcerated he skipped and he's
ever been found again was there any
indication that he was involved with
other men who were participating in
these favors in other words what was the
point of him keeping these uh cards be
unless there was some sort of business
he was an agent
he was an agent and he
had quantities of drugs
mark didn't mention that he listed next
to the name of each boy that boy's
personal drug preference
and he also had a
very large quantity of muscle relaxants
to administer to boys to make sex easier
for the men
not only that but there was also the
names of several
several well-known business
men
in the texas community
that
for obvious reasons were contacts
okay what about you talk about boy scout
groups and boys homes
what about these well
a boy's home is an ideal place
if you want to
get in on an operation and get hold of
some vulnerable kids it's an ideal place
to do it in san antonio this august
two men who were supposed to be catholic
priests uh were arrested for sodomizing
fifty boys ages three and a half to
fourteen
that year and they had
several hundred boys in the past three
years
they're having sex with the boys on a
regular basis that was why they
established the home to get at little
boys
in dallas
a place was closed down the year before
in houston jimmy was in a home in
houston for a while and he was raped by
his caretaker that place was closed down
in houston there are only 42 beds
available in all the homes for boys in
the whole city and one of the homes
that's still open was previously
investigated and arrests were made
because of attacks on the boys
it's very common it's very hard to trust
any place that presents itself as a home
for boys
and one of the tragedies of that is when
somebody opens one that is clean like
covenant house in new york city operated
by father bruce ritter
the first thing that happens is there's
a smear campaign against it and
everybody says it's dirty too
so if there's a clean one it gets a bad
name
the object is that
to make it impossible to tell the good
ones from the bad ones
i guess the boy scout people have this
problem too yes
we've mentioned a couple of boy scout
rings that doesn't mean that the boy
scouts
are an organized group to
feed peters
what about judges and police
judges and police are in high pressure
professions too
some of these too to my knowledge the
police are involved less
as practitioners of this than the other
stressful professions by far um we
mentioned i should have mentioned the
clergy with all regret the clergy is
highly susceptible to this
real priest not just bogus priests like
those in
san antonio you mentioned some of the
worst phenomena here these mass murders
in houston and in chicago does this
connect with atlanta in any way there's
been as you know mass murders of all
these black children in atlanta and as i
recall the fbi uh when they initially
got in the case after they made this a
federal case reagan or i guess it was
bush went down there
the fbi came out with a report that
indicated that there may be sex abuse of
some sort in the death of these children
then it seemed to be pretty much dropped
after an initial play in the media do
you have any comments on that
yes
the first indications that leaked out
that maybe the kids who were victimized
in atlanta murdered
were
actually
boy prostitutes who went to the people
in the cars to make contact
came out in february
and then
national their cable news network
and abc news
tried to mention this as a possibility
it's a very delicate thing
it's almost an insult and a front to the
black community to say the angels of
atlanta
were really prostitutes
unless you believe as i do
and unlike that law professor i quoted
unless you believe they're victims
they're not responsible for what what is
happening they are being used and abused
but the public reaction was chilly so
the networks dropped it they revived it
in april
and
dropped it again i have headlines here
quotations from news broadcasts about
the boys possibly being hustlers and
that fellow who has been arrested
indicted being a photographer procurer
among
the
mothers of the first 10 kids those women
who went public and talked about their
predicament
is one who said to the wire services in
an interview
i'm afraid my son was involved in
prostitution i'm afraid that that's what
got him killed i'm afraid it's the link
to the whole
series of murders and no newspaper in
america printed the wire service copy
isn't
part of this whole phenomenon dealt with
a business of
pornography child pornography
are taken of these acts films are made
and it's wayne williams we know is a
photographer and we know he has training
and electronics he'd done radio work
he'd done recording work so might he be
involved in a film
organization and indeed possibly even a
snuff organization there's been some
evidence about snuff films where people
are literally killed
on film and these are distributed the
films so is there some possibility that
that might be involved i think it's
possible i think it's likely we're
talking about an ongoing case and i
think we have to be very careful about
what we say
in houston i have seen myself
big vans that don't have cabs on them
and i've seen young kids go into the van
and not emerge for an hour or an hour
and a half
and sometimes with the door open i've
seen photographic equipment inside
a raid was made on a mansion in houston
although the newspapers in houston
referred to it as a flat
it was a mansion
inside that mansion was more
photographic equipment than klrn klru
possesses and that's one of the biggest
stations in the southwest
bigger than channel 13 in houston
possesses
channel 13 played up the raid but the
news media besides channel 13 didn't it
was as if uh five guys in a little
studio were taking candid camera shots
of kids they were producing books in
there
there was also an arrest in houston uh
in 1981
of a man who sold
20 different films
child pornography films
to somebody from boston now he was
committing several federal crimes and
doing that all right
and among those films although the
newspapers would not print the
information
among those films was that of an infant
being sexually used by men
and a film in which somebody appears to
have been murdered
that
that person hasn't gone to jail yet what
about the bookstores and the the places
where they show
movies and stuff like this
here here in town i think how much you
don't find much evidence this sort of
thing in the bookstores because it's
people who are trading and dealing with
this kind of thing it's very clandestine
operation and having gone through an
investigation myself i know how
absolutely impossible it is to trail
this stuff
i mean you're dealing with people who
are not stupid
you know they are levels of power
because they're intelligent people
by and large
and they they cover their tracks and
they're not about to be dealing with
them through the bookstores i think
maybe five years ago you could find that
sort of thing
but now it's i think it's been pretty
much cleaned up tom may have well i went
into a
bookstore in austin two years ago
in daylight
and
my experience is the difference between
the operation and daytime and nighttime
is the difference between night and day
yet
in daylight i first bought a magazine
that had pictures of people of
borderline age they could have been 18
that could have been 17
and 17 is legal
and then i
had the names of illegal publications i
first asked for a register that listed
uh boys
by description uh it was a a catalog you
ordered a boy i asked for it in a
bookstore you're in austin it's a crime
to to print that
to reproduce it to distribute it to buy
it to possess it i broke the law by
saying i want that and the guy reached
under the counter handed it to me and i
said what about this and he handed me
that and i said what about this one he
handed me one more
and i walked out of there with a lot of
illegal goods that was in the daytime i
understand
that
as of now 1981 the same bookstores don't
let somebody they don't know do that
sort of thing even at night
but i've been in places uh
in houston
within the last several months
one in particular i can describe you had
40 cubicles
where supposedly men go in and put in
quarters to watch dirty movies
and outside every cubicle was a little
boy
i was approached both by little boys
as if i were a man who might want a boy
and i was approached by older men who in
the dark thought i looked young
uh
that was on a week night not on friday
or saturday
in houston when i started following up
some films that we heard were
circulating in the houston area i called
an old friend of mine while i was
investigating another case involved in
this
because we heard that it had been viewed
by the district attorney's office in
houston
this friend was a good friend who had
known through
[Music]
from bars you know i mean a very social
atmosphere not a professional one
i called him to ask about
if he had heard anything about this film
or reviewed it himself perhaps
he answered the phone i said hello we
chatted for a moment i said by the way
have you heard anything about this film
and he cut me off and said i've never
talked to you before in my life boom
i've never talked to him again and i've
known this guy for a couple years as
soon as i mentioned that film it's like
when boys for sale was shown on tv it
was shown first as a nightly series and
then there was a summary program
the biggest bank in houston withdrew its
advertising from the show
and from the station because it showed
that program
and uh
the bank managed to get the other the
other advertisers for that program to
withdraw their advertising and if i
might interject this just for a moment
because
it ties into the power of
problems
i remember originally with the robert
anderson pharmacist we talked about
earlier
one of the items found in this apartment
was a wallet
or checkbook i guess
with a student's
address and name on it
well we started to make some phone calls
and trying to contact this person we
finally got through to his father and it
turned out it was the
one of the major banks in dallas his
father was the bank president
and we thought we had a hot lead going
and next we know a very i can't mention
names here but a very powerful
law enforcement agency
head
called us and we were asking about this
individual's name in dallas
and he called us back and said
and it was so cryptic it was unusual he
just said
all i can say is forget dallas you know
like don't touch it
a texas house committee has been charged
with looking at the problem two public
hearings later the committee has been
unable to make any serious progress its
budget was slashed from eighty thousand
to fifteen thousand dollars hardly
enough to do an honest probe and the
committee chairman admits to knowing of
the problem in houston but says he's
been told to back off when we started
this committee we asked for money to do
an adequate investigation to determine
just how serious the problem of child
pornography child prostitution sexual
exploitation is here in texas which i
think is is a a proper
thing for this committee to do
now that was the first indication that
we had pressure on us the second
indication was when i appeared before
the house administration committee when
they chopped our budget and subsequent
conversations with certain members that
said
we
have got to stop our investigation do
they want you to stop i don't know why
i have no you plan to find out i plan to
find out i think it's serious that they
were getting this kind of pressure
the concluding program of boys for sale
will emphasize the law enforcement and
judicial performances the handling of
the subject by the mass media and will
provide a more intimate understanding of
the lives of the children involved
there is
big business organized crime it's
sophisticated it's closely attached to
the major financial commercial
industrial
educational institutions of our society
it's run by the same people who run
those it's frequented by the same people
who occupy management positions in those
it's not the mafia
it's
it's an adjunct of clean business
it's serving the most respectable people
we have
in our society the people who are the
elite
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network
p.o box 7279 austin texas
78712
we would like very much to hear from you
if you'd like to participate on
alternative views in some way
or would like to see a previous program
repeated please contact us
the subject of alternative views news
magazine for the evening is boy
prostitution
the widespread use and abuse of male
children for sexual purposes
some of the language in the program may
be offensive to some people
admittedly
the whole subject
is offensive
investigations in other cities have
shown that boys 13 14 even younger are
coerced into prostitution with threats
of physical violence and are sometimes
shipped across state lines shipped to
the older adult men who desire young
boys for sexual acts occasionally these
boys episodes with their older clients
ends in physical violence there are men
who seek young boys to torture and
sometimes to kill young boy prostitutes
14 and 15 years old explained one reason
they sell their bodies to older men is
for money for some especially the
runaways the money means survival a
child an adolescent psychiatrist
explained another motivation as revenge
against a father stepfather or older man
who sexually molested him at an earlier
age best information i have is that
these kids die
they waste away
they kill themselves somebody kills them
that's it and we're talking about over
half over half of the kids who make
their living this way for a period
don't survive adolescence
the slaughter of the innocents it's the
greatest slaughter of the innocent since
herod
and it goes on and on and on and when
the public gets a hint of it
nothing happens
part two of boys for sale the tragedy of
male children being sexually exploited
by older men tonight on alternative
views news magazine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in our previous program the first
section of this two-part series on boys
for sale
the widespread use and abuse of
youth
for the gratification of various men
around the country
we talked about the general nature who's
involved what kids where they come from
how they got involved in it
the
nature of the men themselves the ages
the fact that they come from the highest
the socio and economic and political
stratum of the american american society
the fact that this is a very widespread
thing
and that is hushed up generally and it's
extremely violent kids are killed many
kids are killed and tortured every year
as well as abused
tom philpott
is still with us history professor
university texas mark mckinnon former
editor of the
daily texan
but before we get into tonight's program
further
we will review some of the most
important points of the first section of
boys for sale
for people who may not have seen the
first program
investigations in other cities have
shown that boys 13 14 even younger are
coerced into prostitution with threats
of physical violence and are sometimes
shipped across state lines shipped to
the older adult men who desire young
boys for sexual acts occasionally these
boys episodes with their older clients
ends in physical violence there are men
who seek young boys to torture and
sometimes to kill the
president's
commission on obscenity found this is
the commission that richard nixon
repudiated
it mentioned in passing
that child pornography was a phenomenon
of the abuse of children and then went
on to say that for every female
prostitute of any age in the united
states there are nine boys underage who
are prostitutes and there was a call boy
ring operated out of new york city
which had phone hookups with houston
atlanta los angeles new orleans
washington dc
and that callboy ring had a list of 10
000 clients
who could call and with a credit card
purchase a boy
hello
hello this is uh
credit card number 06789 i'd like to
make an order please go ahead
i'm looking for a young male blonde hair
blue eyes
body hair nobody here thick body here
please what age
10 to 12
butch or femme
butch please
what is your address
i'm at the houston marriott hotel room
wire
313
two hundred dollars now by credit card
and have a hundred dollars in cash for
the boy he'll be there in 30 minutes
thank you thank you
in houston i i give the figure based on
i think prudent calculations that
upwards of 350 boys a year are killed
deliberately because of this many more
die of drug overuse
malnutrition of suicide the national
toll per year
is in the thousands every year kids die
violently because of this
and to the best of my knowledge most men
who seek sex from boys are not
homosexuals
to the extent that they have active sex
lives uh at the peer level
they are heterosexual
many of them have no peer sex at all
there are
gay people who are
what we call petrus that is men who lust
after children especially boys
but it appears to be the case that most
such men are not gay
that they're uh attraction is for
young
defenseless
children especially boys because they're
more exotic more forbidden
but
it is not a matter of
gay
rights
as advocated by practically anybody this
is a
a much different sort of phenomenon the
reason that the gay community
usually
scorns any investigation of the subject
is that they know
that the average person in the public
will blame homosexuals and homosexuality
for the phenomenon regardless of what
facts are presented the kind of
individuals involved are down the line
almost in every instance in the cases
i've investigated men who are very
powerful usually very wealthy
and usually administrate control over a
large number of people sixteen-year-old
boy came to us telling how he'd started
as a prostitute at age twelve and now is
employed by a large houston corporation
the corporation pays him from a
well-covered slush fund
i'm working right now you know like
just you know with the corporation
and
what's that how does that work
well
when their executives or
you know their business people are in
town
they're sent to our apartment
and we entertain them while they're here
okay what's that entertainment usually
involved what do they usually demand or
what do they want
well it's all kinds of sex and
perversions there's no two alike i
decided that
subsequent to the making of this
interview
this boy's mutilated body
was found it's closely attached to
the major financial commercial
industrial
educational institutions of our society
it's run by the same people who run
those it's frequented by the same people
who occupy management positions in those
it's not the mafia
it's
it's an adjunct of clean business
it's serving the most respectable people
we have
in our society the people who are the
elite the texas house committee has been
charged with looking at the problem two
public hearings later the committee has
been unable to make any serious progress
its budget was slashed from eighty
thousand to fifteen thousand dollars
hardly enough to do an honest probe and
the committee chairman admits to knowing
of the problem in houston but says he's
been told to back off when we started
this committee we asked for money to do
an adequate investigation to determine
just how serious the problem of child
pornography child prostitution sexual
exploitation is here in texas which i
think is is a a proper
thing for this committee to do
now that was the first indication that
we had pressure on us the second
indication was when i appeared before
the house administration committee when
they chopped our budget and
subsequent conversations with certain
members that said
we
have got to stop our investigation do
they want you to stop i don't know why
i have no you plan to find out i plan to
find out i think it's serious that
they're that we're getting this kind of
pressure
let's continue
talking about the situation
you have a story here which
kind of
is
good for several aspects of who's
involved what happens to them and what
doesn't happen to them okay i'll read a
wire service
release
which came out of dallas
and which said at the top broadcasters
note nature repeated broadcasters note
nature
and also said note discretionary
material
here's the copy a 30-year state human
resources department employee has been
arrested in dallas on charges of
sexually abusing a child
the department of human resources
officials say 55-year-old howard ray
parker was suspended yesterday from his
job as medical services programs
director statewide
police say they found two to three
hundred pictures of nude boys in
parker's home
officers say a sixteen-year-old runaway
boy alleged parker had sex with him
while he lived with parker
a spokesman for the department of human
resources in dallas says the 30-year
veteran boy charged on sex offenses has
been suspended without pay
it goes on to say that this is routine
procedure
repeats that he's charged with the abuse
of a child he picked up on the street as
the kid was hitchhiking
says that the boy alleges that parker
kept him in that apartment of his for a
month
and that parker repeatedly attacked him
during that time
police say a search of parker's house
uncovered two to 300 photographs of boys
in various states of attire and many
showed them engaging in sex now
it happens to be the case that those
boys were charges of the department of
human resources
and here's what happened in the case
mr parker went under the care of a
psychiatrist
the psychiatrist said that prosecution
would be
damaging to mr parker and prevent his
recovery
the judge took that into consideration
the pre-trial hearing
and let him go
and the state of texas paid for his
psychiatric care and they returned him
to the job after his rehabilitation he
went back to work he went back to work
what about the kids
did they do anything to rehabilitate
them
whatever they were supposed to be doing
in the first place
let's take a look at the children
involved in their lives
robin lloyd author of for money or love
the definitive book on boy prostitution
in america i think that
it's been described as a national
national horror i don't think it's a
national heart i think it's a national
tragedy my findings are that the boys
that get into this
as described in the title of the book
for money or love
they're not really in it for the money i
think that they're in it for what they
perceive to be
adult attention or adult affection
[Music]
that's where it becomes a tragedy if you
take a 12 year old boy who comes into a
strange town
he's broke
he's cold he doesn't have anything he's
hungry
and then the other street boys will tell
him hey you know you've got something
you can sell
and he finds he has this marketable
commodity i mentioned earlier
so now he goes to the apartment with a
strange man
they go to bed together
[Music]
the next day he's out on the street and
he's looking for now
the same kind of
protection that same night their life is
sad it's 100 sad they get up you know
one or two or three during the day and
they go out and they have to earn money
and they're treated bad
they eat only when they're
fed by somebody else and they never get
anything for anything they always have
to return sexual favors for it they
sometimes get beaten they get robbed
they get pushed you know the police
abuse them everybody abuses them what do
you do with the money
[Music]
we gotta get more than five dollars
trying to get some money but when we
need it bad
i don't get 20 bucks for the days of um
[Music]
yeah
most of the kids don't want to be where
they are they don't want to
engage in this lifestyle and if you give
them help
an awful lot of them a very high
percentage of them are quite anxious
either to go home or
to get a job go back to school to live a
normal happy life they are not into this
really rotten thing because they like it
if they stay in it long enough
they develop attitudes
that make it very difficult for them to
do anything else
if you work here in our center and you
do not develop a bad memory
you don't work there very long
the tragedies the violence the
the uh
the fact that
some of the kids that come into us are
killed because they cannot escape the
exploitation is a very hard thing to
bear
our staff does not really last very long
here
who's running it
i can't tell you
why they do something
someone
yeah i understand what you're saying
well if they have that many kids
what's what's their uh
where where is it located i mean is it
what part of town
but you're not gonna
the youth then detailed how boys are
procured and then held by the service
strictly all the boys recently slowed
circuit all the boys
oh no these guys
you know like hitchhikers that are
hitchhiking in they pick them up give
them a place to stay and then tell them
look
you owe us
[Music]
all the way up to what 18 20
20.
do they provide y'all with protection
i mean
are they protected well vice doesn't
touch them
but you don't know why or do you know
what i don't know
all i know is bikes doesn't touch me
do they teach the kids how to perform
sexually at this place they teach them
how to do
i mean like we're usually biggest
what happens if a kid won't perform they
kind of get down on them pretty heavy
you know they just get rid of them
but how they keep it flying
yeah so they won't talk
well they usually have an example
once i
[Music]
our undercover investigator a former
drug rehabilitation counselor and sex
therapist that they are not proud of
what they do
you don't live at home
i go home once in a while
your mother know you do that she doesn't
care
she don't like me come around the house
too much
if i do that she'll let me come around
too much why not
she said she just don't like her son
beating us and stuff like that she knows
you're hustling yeah
this dude wanted to take some pictures
of me 400 tonight
you know
stuff like that
this is stupid stuff
second yeah why do you say it's stupid
you're doing it
well hey
you gotta live i'm ashamed of the day
you're ashamed oh sure
why
hey man i wasn't brought up this way
what kind of family are you from
uh
i had real nice people i mean you know
it was me that messed it your parents
know what you're doing oh no you know
i've never let them know
and i've heard them too many ways
already
well the reason i'm here is you know
when i was 13 years well i was 10 years
old
when my mom got remarried
and when she did this
thing she married
came into my room and raped me and they
had to take me to the hospital and put
three stitches in me
you know that's when you were 10
yeah so then what happened
and i'm leaving homeless when i
when i turned 13 i just you know packed
up my bags and trucked mine what do your
parents think you're doing or what's
your mother think you're doing that
i don't know what they think i haven't
written them a letter since uh
year before last they don't carry
nothing
no this boy was partially a victim of
poverty on the streets though you find
boys from varied backgrounds one
fifteen-year-old from a wealthy family
tells of being cast out because he was
failing in school his parents are
divorced neither his father nor his
mother wants to care for him he started
out as a prostitute when he was
i mean you know where's a twelve year
old going to get a job man
it wasn't too likely
what do you think about what you do you
proud
no
i think
disgusting revolting you know right i
want to do something that's disgusting
to revolt what do you got to eat you got
to sleep you know
the worst i could do is kill me you know
well that's pretty bad
yeah i mean aren't you worried about
that don't you value your living
no right now i don't you know value your
life
not really you don't want to stay alive
i mean i i want to stay alive and all
but you know if i die what
i mean it can't be much worse
i know i mean is it that bad out there
don't you did you look forward to the
day when you get a good job
yeah but that's all i can do is look
forward you know live each day as it
comes so you're really not happier
no
i'd much rather be at home you know well
down in houston they have streets where
they hustle which you don't find in some
other cities right that's right
but kind of now this apparently these
are the entrepreneurs there's the
dc guy talked about right these are cold
little kids looking for
money to buy some food money to get a
room hopefully with some privacy
with somebody if they can't get any
privacy
to put it in
the bluntest terms
at two in the morning when the bars
close
the boys who had only one customer that
night and need more money or haven't had
any customers at all start bidding
against each other for the favors of
whatever pedros are patrolling the
street you've actually observed this yes
yes
that's at two o'clock it lasts for about
an hour a little longer and then some
kids are left and many of them have
nowhere to go
they might have what they call a trick
pad that they can go to and i hope they
get the 25 bucks to pay the rent there
the next day i've seen them climb under
cars to get shelter and warmth
to sleep yes at four in the morning on
this one night in november when it was
cold and the boys had t-shirts on that
jackets and they didn't have jackets
these are mostly uh destitute where you
might say street people well they might
come from well-to-do homes doug but when
they're gone for a few months they're
bored
they are now poor
a rough count that i made was that there
are 400 kids in an area of
half a square mile is there any let me
finish the story
the police then came and rounded them up
in vans
and i heard over police radio that their
account was that there were 400 kids and
they drove them to a suburb of houston
called pasadena and let them out
why'd they do that
they did it because if they formally
arrested them they would have had to
book them and put them someplace and
they had no room for them if they had
room for them they couldn't have
protected them from other people in the
jails
they didn't have the heart to arrest
them
technically they arrested them by taking
them into custody but they didn't have
the heart to do anymore they wanted to
clean up the street because this was the
week before the national election in
1980
they had no place
to find shelter for them because there
were only 42 beds in the whole city and
some of those were questionable as to
their safety for the boys
so they took them for a ride and let
them out they didn't have anything else
to do
tom is race a factor here and if so in
what degree what extent
it's a factor in a surprising way
frank
we've already mentioned but maybe not
emphatically enough that these kids are
poor
once they're out on the street even if
they come from middle class families
they become poor
but overwhelmingly the runaway kids are
from poor families from struggling
families
you would assume then that they would be
heavily minority kids this isn't the
case
overwhelmingly the kids who are
throwaways runaways
who hit the streets and work
in the life
are white
part of the reason is that the market
among the well-to-do men
four boys
is a white market the men want white
kids they don't want chicanos they don't
want black kids they want white kids
fair kids
nordic looking kids
the ideal type what about wealthy black
or chicano males they also tend to
prefer white kids
you can find in what's called the farm
league
in the parks on the streets at the curbs
totally on their own
living hand to mouth roughing it you can
find minority kids but they have a hard
time they have a hard time getting
customers mostly they get employed
in the dark literally they work in the
cubicles
in the magazine stores where their
customers won't see them
there's an ugly term called glory hole
for uh
the kind of thing that happens in the
cubicles
uh
i i think the name is suggestive enough
itself what it means it means that the
customer doesn't have to see
the person who's servicing him and then
the person who's getting the service
fantasizes that the little boy is blonde
and blue eyed and white
well what's the atlanta then you were
talking in the previous program about
this being the situation with the
atlanta kids well i think there are
indications as i said that the kids
there are hustlers
they are hustlers who are out working to
help their families they are not
throwaways they are not runaways
and they are in the farm circuit they
are working out of a park
uh they're not in
the penthouses they're not in call boy
services
uh black kids are out there working and
they're not getting the best trade
they're getting what is called rough
trade
men who will pay less and want more and
be more likely to inflict violence as
part of the price
another thing i'd like to say here is
that
on the basis of what i've learned over
the last three years
i have a
feeling
it's not a firm conclusion by any means
but it's a strong feeling
that there's a second reason why the
kids out there caught up in this
are primarily white
the first reason is that the rich men
want white boys i think there's a second
reason
and that is
that poor struggling black families are
taking better care of their kids than
white families are
they're not pushing them out the boys
aren't running away they're keeping the
contact with home even if they do have
to resort to this for economic reasons
and when the families find out it's
happening
they accept the kids and they love them
and they don't punish them reject them
and throw them out what about the kids
themselves what happens to them assuming
they're ones that live and
can they get out of the life and what
happens to them when they do what are
they like
in the first place they mostly don't
survive
they mostly literally don't live to be
20 years old
as far as i know the best information i
have is that these kids die
they waste away
they kill themselves somebody kills them
that's it and we're talking about over
half over half of the kids who make
their living this way for a period
don't survive adolescence they don't
become adults
those who do have a tremendously
difficult time
of course it does damage it does
tremendous damage to self-esteem
you have to grow up with a general
bitterness towards towards adults where
you find with all this all these
strangers now into your life where
you're literally being used and poured
over mutilated it's not even damage is a
a quiet word for the the mutilation of a
child's spirit we cannot take a seven or
eight year old and think that seven or
eight year old has the same sexual needs
and drives and concepts as you and i
we have to realize the children see
things differently use material
differently and have different ways of
integrating experience
children cannot integrate anal sodomy at
eight or nine
the fact is it's it's all they know how
to do it's all they're good at
i came to know very well
a 22 year old
hustler
masquerading as a 16 year old
for whom
friends and i were able to find a job
but it wasn't a good enough job for him
he knew the risks
over the years he although he was white
and blonde
he had to do more and more and more
for less and less and less turn more and
more tricks a day as he got older as he
got older
one of the things that i know happened
to him
in the last year was that he had to be
subjected
to penetration with bottles
and the men played the game of whether
or not they'd break the bottle off in
him or not
and cut him
that kind of thing when he was 17 he
didn't have to do that and he got more
money
at 22
he pretended he was 16.
the man pretended he was 16 he got less
money
he had to turn more tricks
but he didn't know what else to do
he felt it was the one thing he was good
at
he also admitted to being miserable what
are some of the legal problems here
how come more of
one the organization that's exploiting
these boys hasn't been uncovered
and uh to the men who are participating
in these uh crimes again take the boys
homes for instance
uh in the case in san antonio which is
still pending
there was an eyewitness who walked into
the room of the director of the home at
four in the morning because he was sure
there would be a little boy in there and
there was a six-year-old boy in bed with
this
supposed priest now the eyewitness
testimony that a boy was in bed with an
old man
doesn't do anything in the courtroom it
doesn't prove that there was sex going
on
if the little boy testifies
who is going to take the word of a
little boy against the word of say a
real priest and what little boy is going
to say that a priest violated
it's a harder arrest to make it's hard
to get a warrant
it's hard to get an arrest
it's hard to get a conviction and then
it's hard to get a real sentence
very hard nobody wants to put anybody
away on this kind of charge because the
evidence is
by its nature
very very shaky
and very controversial as well and that
just points to another facet of this
problem is that
often it's just ignored
preferentially ignored by the courts and
by the police and by society because i
just don't want to believe it's
happening i remember when we did our
reports we thought it's significant
enough
because the nature of the case involves
some austin personnel and citizens
that we put it on the front page because
i was shocked personally by it
and when we printed these stories we
just were barraged with letters from
people saying
basically
i don't want to read this kind of stuff
over my morning coffee
you know even though it happened even
though we documented it and we'd gone
out of our way to make sure it was all
backed up with fact people just refused
to want us
not only to believe it but to even
believe that it happens
so that's part of the problem another
part of the problem is
of course we were shocked when we found
out the extent and broad nature of this
problem of pederasty
and what all it involves but we were
truly shocked when we found out
originally initially when we started
this few years a few years back
that the police department didn't even
know what heterostate was i mean i ran
in i won't say the police department but
i know that i was dealing with one
officer in sex crimes division who's no
longer in sex crimes division
and i was trying to get
do my part for
truth and justice
and trying to get to the root of the
problem and i said well tell me about
your uh case history of pederasty
and he just went blank he had no idea
what i was talking about now to their
credit i will say that the austin police
sex crimes division has come a long way
since then but if the police don't know
what it is then certainly most members
of society won't know what it is so when
they see it in the papers
and editors don't know what it is so
they're not going to print in the first
place but occasionally when it does go
through
society just writes it off as an
aberration of very you know well how is
the police how are the police organized
you mentioned sex crime division but
they have a sex crime there's also the
bi squad so what's the sex crimes vision
is a subset of advice no it's part of
homicide in almost every city
it's part of homicide advice has to do
with pornography obscenity prostitution
things involving consenting adults which
may be crimes if they're performed in
public or commercially a sex crime is
something that involves
a direct violation of the law or
involves things with kids or
child pornography do you have a feel for
say the budget and the
number of personnel and vice squads
compared to
sex crime divisions in various places
uh no i i really don't frank that's
something i don't know more about
the emphasis the city
the police department places on one i do
in austin at that time anyway at that
time they had three people in the entire
sex crimes division
and they were so overworked with just
you know that's when the choker rapist
was around what have you and i mean
that's
that pretty much exhausts their time and
they were concerned about the issue but
they just said frankly we're not staffed
we don't have the personnel to do it
rape is a major crime the incidence is
high attempted rape is common it's
extremely hard to track down a rapist
these guys are working extremely hard
and then
we charge them with the duty of
cleaning up the streets
and in austin the streets are clean
houston they're not
but how can they go behind the walls and
find out what's going on indoors that's
extremely hard to do has has there been
much investigation by any police or the
fbi or the judicial system of this
phenomenon
or is it that it's a fairly recent
phenomenon or is it just something that
they haven't dealt with
historically or currently there have
been legislative investigations
there was a national investigation a
couple of years ago
looking toward the goal of national
legislation to protect kids
but no there hasn't been much there are
some who would like to tell us that the
problem does not exist but to say
houston is a major center for boy
prostitution is to overstate the case
that is what the houston police tell us
there again
it's not we don't have as many
male prostitutes as we do female
prostitutes but when you start talking
about juvenile boys
14 15 16 years old
two or three cases are too many
and
we do have a few of those
how would you
talk about that a little further how
would you define the problem of
young boy prostitution in houston as far
as
the size of the problem
well i'm not going to say it's
one of the major problems
of our city
again we have a certain amount of it and
it's our intention to try to keep the
lid on it to keep it from getting any
worse listen to atlanta police sex
crimes detective douglas mccoy a 10-year
veteran
it is almost at this point
especially at this time of the year
almost an epidemic yet only a very few
young boys are ever arrested in 1978
there were seven
so far in 1979 we've had three male
prostitution charges
the facts are the atlanta police
department is understaffed vice and sex
crime detectives carry a heavy workload
rapes for example are up almost 100
percent this year boy prostitution is
near the bottom on the priority list
local police have to change their
attitudes towards the boys thinking of
them more as victims than as criminals
the change in philosophy has worked for
the los angeles police department and
serves as an example for other cities
you've got a 15 year old boy
out on the street selling his body
you've got to understand why he's out
there
it's usually
due to a poor
home life
he's there to obtain the necessities of
life and you've got to look at that boy
as a victim
even though he's out there committing
the crime of prostitution you still have
to look at him as a victim and why he's
out there when you do bring them in what
do you do with them you certainly don't
just throw them in the county jail
somewhere
we
it takes us anywhere from two to six
hours to interview you talk to one of
these
boys for two to six hours when you first
get them in yes sir
initially they
don't have trust in the police
department because it's usually
they've had contact with uniform
policemen
and the uniformed policemen will book
them curfew or run away and they're sort
of leery of the police department
we'll sit down and we'll gain
the kids confidence we'll talk to him
we'll tell him if he is involved in
anything that he has
anything having to do with sex that he
has done nothing wrong at all
and
we treat him the best we can we'll keep
in contact with the victims and we keep
calling them weeks later and we'll go
out and we'll buy them lunch and this is
weeks later you go out and get together
and see how the boys are doing
progressing and
they call us quite a bit
rehabilitation for young boy prostitutes
necessitates a change in the way they
are handled by penal institutions in san
francisco boy prostitutes from around
the nation congregate near some of the
plushest hotels but in san francisco a
boy prostitute who was arrested is given
special treatment sheriff richard
hungisto has set up a new program to
deal with young boys the heterosexual
inmates
are very likely to abuse to rape
the
younger person or the person they think
has had
homosexual experiences on the streets
they will take advantage of them
by force and sometimes they will be very
very brutal it's a problem amongst
children juveniles and adults so what
has been your answer here
we house the gay inmates separately we
don't mix them in with
a heterosexual population just for that
reason
and of course the same thing is true
with juveniles as you view this problem
and people like this come in off the
street how do you handle them well what
we do here is to do what we can to make
sure that if there are any psychological
problems that they're dealt with
and also to try to aid them with post
post-release
help
giving them
opportunities as much as we can to find
a job to have a place to stay and get
back on their feet so that they don't
have to sell their bodies
to make money here in austin
the sex crime unit now is
to my observation a solid unit doing the
best it can and they have something
that's rare in the whole state they have
an officer whose sole job is to counsel
the victims of sex
crimes she's an old student of mine and
a friend of mine
her job was funded by the u.s government
she lost her job
in the reagan budget last month and she
had to fight lobby in in the city
council to get retained as a police
officer they've retained her for a year
but the overall budget was cut and her
job
you know will remain in jeopardy and
it's a vital job
if i could just add to the problems of
investigation and
how tom and i learned about all this
we just finally realized that tom
thankfully has carried on and updated
the material and kept close look my
full participation only last for a
period of about six months to a year
when you were a reporter when i was a
reporter
and myself and another former editor of
the daily texan just
as soon as we got hooked on it i mean as
soon as we found out what was going on
we went after it with entire abandon
for a good period of three to six months
almost every day we spent
we forgot our classes we forgot our work
at the newspaper we just we were
determined to get to the root of it
and after six months we had touched the
tip of the iceberg and we realized at
that time after spending inordinate
amounts of time money and energy which
we didn't have to spend already
that we needed to be funded by some sort
of organization much larger than
ourselves
and a staff much larger than ourselves
to continue to find out really what was
going on so i can see how law
enforcement agencies with what little
funding they have particularly during a
tax
time such as ours that's hard to do
and as i said the more we found out
the more questions
propped up and in a deeper because
there's so many things if it's all right
to range around a little bit here
it ought to be said
that in academia there's been virtually
no contribution
i learned about this whole phenomenon as
a teacher when a student of mine called
my attention to the tv documentary boys
for sale which was made in houston i was
embarrassed that i didn't know anything
about the subject
mentioned it to sociologists
anthropologists psychologists social
workers they didn't know anything about
it either then i went into the
bibliography and found that it was first
meager and second
heavily oriented toward the defense and
explication of the pederst like the
lawyers commentary i quoted to you
is considered a dirty subject and people
aren't supposed to go into it
every semester when i lecture on it i
have students get up and walk out
i used to have
complaints made to the department
to
the college to the university and so on
that i was doing pornographic things in
the classroom
that that's abated but people still get
upset and walk out maybe not because
they are offended but because they're
emissarated by it and they want to get
away from it
people don't like to look at reality
well especially those realizations this
stuff is horrible
uh
at any rate if if the police department
from any major city went over to the
major educational institution in its
area and asked for a contribution from
the faculty that faculty could
contribute practically nothing
academics have been
not necessarily remiss they have been
oblivious
to this can i ask you unless you be able
to compromise your
information system how do you go about
getting your information
observation
uh
interviewing
and
interviewing of many kinds interviewing
kids interviewing people who are willing
to talk or on the other side of the
street
so to speak
and investigators
have you written any books or
are you planning any articles or studies
on this i'm
working on a book and i expect it will
not be the the last book that i'll write
about the subject and i'll be teaching a
course on it
in the spring and as far as i know it'll
be the first one ever taught in an
american college
can we talk about the mass media
treatment we've kind of hit on it here
and there
from
what i seem to get the electronic media
particularly a couple of tv stations
have done most of the work on it and the
newspapers haven't done much the
exception of mark and uh
right with the exception of the texan
right well it's interesting throughout
all the things that we did we thought
and perhaps we were in a minority but we
thought it was
information that was in the best public
interest to know or at least be exposed
to
was not
touched by any other local media in town
do you have any explanation for this why
didn't the austin american statesman
pick up on i really don't know the tv
station did you ever take it to them
but actually i think the statesman did
run one or two
i think they ran the initial story about
anderson the pharmacist being much and
that's what sparked our interest of
course
did you ever talk to the reporter that
did that story and see why they didn't
pursue the no i don't think i did i
think we got so wrapped up in what we
were doing
what about down in houston is there any
evidence of pressure to keep the lid on
down there
well
when boys for sale was shown on tv it
was shown first as a nightly series and
then there was a summary program which
you'll have excerpts of
the biggest bank in houston withdrew its
advertising from the show
and from the station because it showed
that program but they didn't they didn't
withdraw until the last not the last
minute they kept saying if you don't
kill that program tonight we're going to
withdraw our advertising and they did
and
the bank managed to get the other the
other advertisers for that program to
withdraw their advertising uh
the houston post and the houston
chronicle again
that story i mentioned in the previous
program about the bust of this mansion
with this incredibly elaborate film
studio in it
emerges in the post and the chronicle as
a little place with some cameras
yeah and the problem is not so much
that
the incidents are ignored but there's
never any follow-up there's never any
investigation they just take the easy
way out something happened boom it
happened next day it's forgotten what we
need in the media is follow-up and
investigation on everybody's part so
that we won't so that would
become sensitized to the issue
you had some threats of physical
violence also when you were doing this
investigation well this did you know we
were working with some people from
houston who knew a lot more about it
than we did and they of course counseled
us and said beware
i had my windshield broken in
i mean
a brick thrown through my windshield i
don't know if that was
entirely coincidental i sincerely doubt
it just because the timing and nature of
places well this may be one very good
reason why there hadn't been like a
warning why there hadn't been a lot of
investigative reporting now
the moderator of the show
boys for sale had a shotgun go through
blast go through his window and then
another one go through his uh
that is the window of his home and then
another blast go through the windshield
of his car as he was approaching the car
to get into it
that kind of
signal
usually is sufficient
to warn a person off any one of us in
the country
and there aren't very many of us who
have worked intensely on this for a
period of years has received threats
and
has been subject to at least feigned
attempts
and the idea is that that should scare
us off
it has worked with a whole lot of people
the day after part one of boys for sale
was cable cast tom philpot's van was
vandalized
the tires were slashed and the
accelerator was jammed to the floor
and then the following week
tom was shot in what appears to have
been an assassination attempt
has anybody been killed
actually
what about the guy that wrote the book
that he got a shocking blast that did
wound him i think pretty seriously
didn't it well what then should society
do about this how can this problem be
dealt with well
it's a tall question
law enforcement has to
has to be activated and it has to be
supported and has to be seen through
through the end of the procedure so that
you don't have congressmen
pleading not guilty or noah contender
and getting no penalty
the kids who are
rescued in this process have got to be
cared for and helped and no one really
knows how to do it but it's got to be
done a way has got to be found they've
got to be helped and then most obviously
we've got to find a way to to
reestablish a society which does not
throw up literally a half million kids a
year
onto the city's streets and leave them
there to
to be hurt
american families have to have support
it's good enough to say to families love
your children but they have to have the
wherewithal to care for their children
and obviously american families do not
these kids are not minority kids in the
maine but they're mainly poor kids
they're from hard driven hard living
families
and it's so very very sad and
and it's so sad that we need to
respond to them we people who
who've got our stuff together and
who think we know a lot about a lot of
things we just need to reach out to
those kinds of kids we need to go out
there and find them how quickly can a
city like houston move in this area well
we can move as quickly in this area as
we should as we have been in other areas
we can
build a billion dollar houston center
downtown then we can certainly move
quickly to solve human problems and
problems of people
father mcginnis do you see
a role for big business in houston in
in this plan
yeah one role is money
you know and a lot can let's face it a
lot can be done with money a lot of
alternatives can be offered if we have
the money to pay for them and there's
enough excess money
in 10 corporations in this city to do
anything we would want to to save every
one of these kids shocking as it is when
you put into perspective maybe it's
really not
quite so unexpected considering the
history
of what
the people have been subject to who have
been under the control and rule of these
people and you start to think about
what's been done to the indians
the terrible working conditions that
people lived in for years and worked
under for years the dangerous condition
the pesticides
that
people are forced to ingest
the lack of safety in the places where
we work
wars where people are slaughtered
there's really a long history of this
and this is
is this the same type of impulse turned
focused just
on a small boy or is this something
really unique you think
that isn't easy to answer frank because
in all honesty this subject
has baffled me from the time i first
became aware of it
until this day
i can't understand it
and i'm trying very hard and
it's very difficult
as an historian i know that this society
probably above all in the world and in
the history of the world romanticizes
childhood
but the historical record
child labor for one thing indicates the
society has not been good to children
has not protected children
and in fact is contemptuous of children
heartless
to children
and they're such helpless victims
who can they go to
what constituency do they have
nobody
uh the heartlessness that goes into it
is is certainly
somehow connected
with the heartlessness which
ground up
the indians
black people
immigrant laborers
poor people in general which is
motivating the cuts in social programs
today
blindness to the actual living reality
of people's
situations yes it's connected
but this is the
it's about the most hair-raising thing
i think i've encountered in studying the
history of my country
the slaughter of the innocents it's the
greatest slaughter of the innocent since
herod
and it goes on and on and on and when
the can say a hint of it
nothing happens the case of price daniel
is
instructive there it came out
in in the
custody hearing of
mrs daniel who admitted to shooting her
husband
that he attacked their son
and there was testimony that he had
relations with other adolescents
there wasn't any inquiry as to what that
might mean for society price daniel is
one of the major names of texas
and all these other names that we've
mentioned of people have been caught and
let off
there doesn't seem to be any willingness
to make the connections which you have
implied
and face him
and it's time we did right
yeah dan right it's time we did
there needs to be police action there
needs to be action in the academy of
which i am part to study this there has
to be rehabilitation for kids and most
of all american families have got to be
put on a footing where their children
are not in jeopardy of being lost in
this way
whole society has got to answer for this
do something about it if we don't
make this move what do you think the
results would be in houston it would get
worse and worse and worse
and there'd be kids killed
in the dead of night and dumped on the
highway like they are right now
it'll get worse it'll never get better
you don't sit back and see something
like this it's history has proven that
and just watch it and it gets better
it'll get worse much worse
[Music]
where can i go
what am i looking for
[Music]
how can i touch what's deep inside
what have i lost
how can i find
a love
at last
to ease my mind
who can i find
to tell me who i am
[Music]
who can i find to hold me closely
what have i got how can i give
a love
at last
to ease my mind
for love nor money do i seek among
the streets by day or night
[Music]
i've found it is not there
[Music]
but maybe just that one day one time
someday i will find
a love
that lasts my mind
[Music]
who can i find
to tell me who i am
who can i find to hold me closely
[Music]
what have i got
how can i give
a love
it lasts
to ease my mind
[Music]
you